are there a specific set of television
appropriate characters where is there
certain characters that would be better
left to film much more important
distinction is not between film
characters versus TV characters it has
to do with the genre that you're working
in there are certain characters that go
with these different genres now where we
see this most clearly in television is
in the sitcom form now sitcom is a cell
form of comedy there are a number of sub
genres of comedy including romantic
comedy buddy picture satire and so on
but one of them is the sitcom and it
turns out that in sitcoms there are
different character types that these
shows are built on and these character
types are there because they can create
comedy that can create laughs not just
for one joke not just for one episode
for multiple seasons and obviously this
is tremendously valuable because the
entire show is going to be built on how
the audience relates to these characters
and how these characters are relate to
each other and again in comedy we're
always looking at how they really
comically how do they set each other up
to provide jokes so for example we get
in the sitcom we get the scheming hero
we get the happy dad we get the dummy
character we get the know-it-all
character these are some of the
different character types that these
shows are built on for example Frasier
classic know-it-all character right and
when he got his own show as if that
wasn't enough no at all they brought in
his brother who is know-it-all number
two and and there's tremendous comedy
that you can generate over multiple
seasons with this character type the
dummy character type is in a huge number
of
it comes and you know again this is
comedy that can be generated over and
over again we saw this in friends we see
this in Big Bang Theory and so on
although they're there and this is a new
version of this character type it's the
intellectual dummy right to see over
educated dummy the the idiot savant this
is very common now and again it all has
to do with knowing your genre and
knowing the characters that are going to
make that john will work over multiple
seasons
you